it's been
40 years since u.s president richard
nixon
signed the national cancer act promoting
the work of the national cancer
institute
since then clinical care has really
changed overall
u.s cancer mortality rates began to
decline
in the 1990s though for some cancers
things haven't improved an estimated 350
000 people in the united states died in
2010
from the seven deadliest cancers
who gets cancer and what causes it
there are clues in people's genomes and
researchers have identified
many environmental factors carcinogens
that can cause the mutations that lead
to cancer
and perhaps the greatest accomplishment
in cutting down on the incidence of
cancer
has been in prevention limiting or
eliminating
exposures to carcinogens
but in looking at genomes of individual
cancers
it's increasingly clear that there are
certain mutations
in particular genes that drive cancer's
development
now for each individual cancer each
individual cancer clone
we believe that it requires multiple
different driving genes
so that certainly applies to the common
adult epithelial cancers such as cancers
of the breast or the prostate or the
lung
we believe that in each of those cancers
a number of different genes has to be
operative in a single case
the number that is often bandied around
is around maybe five
different cancer genes operating in each
case
it's possible that in some cancers there
are more
and it's also thought that perhaps in
some cancers
particularly of the blood system some
leukemias
it may each individual cancer may
require
fewer than five possibly only one
where researchers have found just one or
a few genes that drive a particular
cancer's growth such as chronic myeloid
leukemia
they've gone on to design drugs that
target the molecular machinery of that
cancer
and stop it from growing and we now know
over the last six to seven years
with inhibitors against other drivers in
cancers
such as lung cancer sarcoma
melanoma glioblastoma
kidney cancer that we can see dramatic
clinical
responses with a single drug targeting a
single
driver the cancers change over time they
evolve and they can become resistant to
these targeted therapies
and there may be other factors that
contribute to a cancer's ability to
spread or grow
rna expression micro rnas
proteins splicing variants
metabolites you know do we need to know
all this in order to make an intelligent
decision
um i think we it's going to depend on
the tumor
and and the mutation
but there's no doubt that the other
variables all
impact how the tumor will progress
and respond to treatment the
the challenge is you can't really wait
for all the other technologies to sort
of reach maturity
uh at the same level that dna sequencing
now has
so the idea is that a patient comes to
see the doctor they're diagnosed with
cancer
the doctor takes a biopsy a sample of
their tumor or cancer
and tests it they test it for genetic
mutations that might be driving the
growth of the cancer
and then they can give that patient a
drug match to the particular mutations
that are
important in their cancer or the doctor
may need to give the patient
a combination of drugs because there's
more than one mutation driving the
growth of their cancer
it's the same idea that's used with aids
patients who receive a cocktail of drugs
for
to stop the hiv virus and one example
where this is being
done is with chronic myeloid leukemia
charles sawyers is working on ways to
to give patients with that disease a
cocktail of drugs
there's some compelling cocktail ideas
um
but we've only got one of the two or
three ingredients we need to
stir the cocktail up correctly one
drug's still experimental whereas one
has already approved or one we just
don't even have the drug yet
uh so that's why um i'm giving you an
answer that's not very satisfying
the science is telling us to do these
cocktails but we just don't have all the
ingredients on the shelf yet
but getting a therapy to work and
getting it to endure are two separate
things
these cocktails of cancer drugs may work
for a while they may
extend a patient's life by many more
months but eventually their tumor is
probably going to develop resistance to
the combinations
in lung cancer an inhibitor to one
driver
can be overcome either by mutation of
the driver as
in the leukemia example or by something
we call
oncogene bypass where another driver
which wasn't driving gets into the
driver's seat and takes over
and therefore you need an inhibitor that
would
work against the second driver it's
still a cocktail
strategy you just have to know who's
driving
so doctors may have to keep testing
their tumor for genetic changes and
giving them a
tailored cocktail every time they start
to resist the previous
combination of drugs and one thing that
will help is finding
more mutations more genetic weak spots
and tumors
by systematically sequencing a lot of
cancers
and that's what mike stratton is working
on with his team
so if we are interested and i think we
should be
in finding genes that are relatively
infrequently mutated but nevertheless
driver genes contributing to cancers
we then have to analyze not ten cancers
but a hundred
and for some of these genes a thousand
and that is at the core of the current
initiatives to sequence cancer genomes
to do really quite substantial numbers
so that we then access more or less
the full repertoire of cancer genes
whether they're operating commonly
in one or more types of cancers or
rarely
the advantage of the targeted cancer
drugs compared to standard chemotherapy
is that they're much less toxic
chemotherapy targets all dividing cells
in the body and so it can be extremely
toxic
while the targeted cancer drugs tend to
act only on the tumor cells
and so there are far fewer side effects
the downside to the targeted therapies
is that cells will inevitably develop
resistance because there will always be
a few
cells in the tumor that have some gene
that allows them to resist the drug
and so the tumor will evolve and
eventually evade the drug
and so the doctor may have to get the
patient another a different drug to
target the
mutated resistant form of their tumor
and this can take only a few months for
this resistance to develop
while developing each new drug can take
10 to 15 years
so many current cancer therapies
do appear to be converting cancers
into chronic diseases rather than
acutely killing
diseases however
what should be our aspiration our
aspiration
should be ultimately to kill the cancer
cells
our aspiration should be to achieve cure
and this is not just banner waving we
know
that it can be done it's not so much
from the recent advances
in targeted cancer therapeutics but we
know from the much earlier advances
in cancer chemotherapy the advances in
the leukemias
particularly of childhood the advances
in testicular cancer
of young men where previous diseases
which had
extremely high mortality now have
90 percent cures because of cancer
chemotherapeutics that
kill all the cancer cells
so it can be achieved and that is still
what we should be
aspiring to what we need to understand
much better is why we achieved those
successes
those decades ago in the leukemias and
testicular cancers
and what are the differences between
those cancers
and those treatments compared to other
cancers
and the targeted treatments we're using
today
i see that the future uh really
it should be the present encounter with
an oncologist
as a combination of an interaction with
the patient
and a detailed molecular analysis of the
tumor at diagnosis
science is published by aaas the science
society